president biden released an executive
order on cryptocurrency laying out a new
potential regulatory agenda but the
order also talked a lot about the
development of a central bank digital
currency i know a lot of you are
thinking wait what's that
well i'm so glad you asked i've been
following this topic for a while and if
you're thinking it's the same thing as
bitcoin
we've got a lot of catching up to do i'm
going to tell you what digital
currencies are and in particular central
bank digital currencies how those differ
from cryptocurrencies
and why the u.s is just now getting
around to talking about releasing one
when countries like china have already
made it a reality let's get into it now
you've probably heard of cryptocurrency
but it isn't the only form of digital
currency in fact some people argue that
crypto isn't currency at all a digital
currency is any money that exists
digitally rather than in paper or coin
form the same way you can pay for things
by pulling bills out of your wallet you
can pay for them with digital currency
from your digital wall
what central bank currencies are not
is bitcoin or any other kind of
cryptocurrency
think about it like this
all sandals or shoes but not all shoes
or sandals right cryptocurrencies are
digital assets made by people that have
a value
central bank digital currency or cbdc
is a digital asset backed by the
country's government and produced by its
central bank since the tokens are
produced by the central bank which is
responsible for printing money they're
the same as cash central bank digital
currencies don't fluctuate in value you
don't trade them they're like the
dollars in your bank account or on your
credit card balance except they're not
held at a bank they're on a digital
ledger and don't require an internet
connection to access so why haven't we
seen the federal reserve rolling out a
digital dollar well that's a bit of a
long story the biggest problem is that
lawmakers and regulators aren't in
agreement that the u.s really needs a
digital dollar
opponents say that the private sector in
the u.s is better equipped to deliver
digital currencies than the government
or the fed george selgen a senior fellow
at the cato institute who held the
center for monetary and financial
alternatives told me recently that he
doesn't think a central bank digital
currency would even be particularly
useful instead the fed should get out of
the way and let the fintech industry do
its thing critics of a digital dollar
point to credit cards and apps like
paypal venmo or zell as proof that the
private sector is on the right track but
legislators like senator elizabeth
warren disagree they're not very
enthusiastic about what they've seen
from fintech companies have already
created what they call stable coins
cryptocurrencies that are tied to the
value of the dollar and don't move in
price
warren is called private stable coins a
risk to consumers and the economy and
senate banking committee chairman
sherrod brown has pressed the companies
behind the most popular stable coins
about a lack of transparency and
consumer protection the fed recently
released a paper on central bank digital
currency but didn't really take a side
in the argument i spoke with fed
governor laelle brainerd last year and
she said the technology piece is largely
there but the fed needs buy-in from
congress and other regulators others on
the fed are worried a central bank
digital currency could hurt banks or
damage the financial system so where
does that leave us well president biden
announced that he's pushing forward with
research and the treasury department
will compile a report on the future of
money and payment systems he's also
pushing for with more review on a
central bank digital currency still the
us is well behind in the development of
a central bank digital currency
in china citizens have been using its
digital currency the e renminbi for more
than a year and during the winter
olympics even rolled it out to tourists
biden's announcement this week suggests
that the us is going to be putting a lot
more thought into digital currencies
before we take action
china is already a leader in this space
and people like brainerd are worried
that with first mover advantage they
could force the us to play catch-up
global financial leaders like the head
of the international monetary fund and
the bank for international settlements
have called central bank digital
currency the future of money it remains
to be seen if the us will get left
behind in that future
if you enjoyed this video make sure to
hit the like button and if you're
interested in markets make sure you
subscribe
as champagne poppy aka drake tells us
guess you win some and lose some as long
as the outcome is income
that's all for now see you next time